سبعه قتلى في زلزال جديد ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وسكان ثلاث دول احسوا بقوته الشديده
تراقب لخطاب بوتين اليوم تزامنا مع مرور
سنه على الاعتراف بانفصال عن اوكرانيا
اشتباكات عنيفه ترافق اقتحام قوات
اسرائيليه لمدينه جنين في الضفه الغربيه
وشن حمله اعتقالات واسعه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا النشره من تركيا
وسوريا اللتين هزهم زلزال جديد بقوه 6
درجات فاصله ثلاثه على سلم الاختر تبعته
هزه ارضيه بقوه خمس درجات فاصله ثمانيه
شعر بها سكان لبنان ومصر واجزاء من العراق
زلزال مسائل اثنين خلف حتى الان سبعه قتلى
على الاقل في كل من تركيا وسوريا كما اعاد
الرعب الى قلوب ما لبثت تهدئ من الزلزال
المدمر الذي قتل اكثر من 47 الف شخص في
البلدين الجارين كاميرا الشوارع رصدت لحظه
الضرب زلزال ليله البارحه نتابع
الله
حاضر
لا اله الا الله
سقوط اجزاء من هذه البنايات ما يدفعنا الى
الرحيل باقصى سرعه من هذا المكان عبد
القادر خربوش لقناتي العربيه والحدث من
مدينه هاتاي جنوب تركيا
ومنها مشاهدينا يبقى معنا مفرد العربيه
عبد القادر خربوش اهلا بك عبد القادر
وانقل ان الصوره رجاء كيف استفاقت هاتاي
صباح هذا اليوم
نتحدث الان عن كيف استفاقت هاتاي صباح
اليوم استفاقت على حجم دمار هائل اضافي
الى الدمار الذي خلفه الزلزال المدمر قبل
اسبوعين عمليات المسح
للبنايات التي تضررت من قبل سلطات التركيه
كانت قد اعلنت بانها بلغت ثلاث ملايين وتم
تحديد اشكال هذه يعني الاضرار التي طالت
البنايات بين
يعني متهالكه متضرره نوعا ما شديده الضرر
ولكن اليوم يبدو الامر انه كل تلك
البنايات صارت الان شديده التضرر وهي الان
ايله للسقوط في ايه لحظه لاحظنا استنفار
كبير جدا منذ ساعات الاولى لنهار اليوم
هنا من قبل
رجال الانقاد وعمليات ازاله الردوم وايضا
رجال الامن والجيش المنتشر بشكل كبير في
هذه المدينه تم تطويق عدد كبير من الاحياء
التي كانت قبل يومين مفتوحه امام الماره
والسيارات الاسعاف ومختلف الاطقم التي
تجوب المدينه في مساعده عمليات الانقاذ
لكن اليوم تم غلق الكثير منها يعني تحسبا
وخشيه وقوع حوادث انهيارات لهذه المباني
التي تصدعت بشكل كبير جراء الزلزال الجديد
او الزلزلين اللذين ضربا المنطقه ليله امس
بشده سته فاصل اربعه على سلم كذلك
5.8 فاليوم حتى من ربما كان لديه نوعا من
الامل للبقاء في هذه المدينه في خيام
لاحظنا صباحا ونحن ندخل
المدينه العديد من
الناجين يغادرون المدينه سيارات هناك من
قابلناهم في احدى المحطات محطات النقل
البري يبحثون عن سبل لمغادره المنطقه
نهائيا سالنا بعضهم الى اين تذهبون هناك
من لا يعرف حتى الى اين يذهب هناك من فقد
اهله هنا وهو الناجي الوحيد هناك من
برفقته اطفال عوائل يبحثون عن اماكن اكثر
امانا يتوقع حتى سكان المخيمات عبد القادر
لم يعد يشعرون بالامان بعد بعد الهزتين
الاخيرتين صحيح
نعم هذا الذي لاحظناه هو هناك بعض
المخيمات الصغيره التي نصبت حتى وسط هاتاي
قبل قليل بالقرب من مقر محافظه ولايه
هاتاي كنا هناك لكن هناك يعني تجديد امني
كبير يمنع التصوير هناك لاحظنا بان الناس
من هم داخل الخيام ليسوا براحه تامه هناك
خوف شديد هناك تطويق لهذه الخيام وعدم
السماح لهم بالخروج والتجول ربما او يعني
يتم السماح لهم فقط في رواق ضيق للحصول
على الاكل على المساعدات التي تقدم لهم
بين الفينه والاخرى
الاعداد الذين قضوا بالامس فقط يعني جراء
هذا الزلزال هنا بهاتاي بلغت سته قتلى
وايضا هناك قرابه 300 جريح بينهم حوالي 20
شخصا في حاله حرجه بحسب التصريحات الرسميه
لوزير الصحه التركي الان خلال هذه الصور
التي نشاهد ربما من هذا من هذا الجانب
عمليات ازاله الردوم بدات بدات بشكل واسع
هنا فيها تاي احمد لا ندري ان كانت عمليات
الانقاذ قد توقفت لحد اللحظه رسميا لم يتم
الاعلان عن ذلك لكن ما شاهدناه خلال
جولتنا لم نلاحظ وجود فرق الانقاذ بمحيط
تواجد هذه الاليات وعمليات رفع الركام ما
يؤشر الى ربما دخول المدينه مرحله جديده
من
تسيير هذه الازمه مثل ما تم الاعلان عن
وقف عمليات الانقاذ بباقي الولايات ما
يعني انه الاسراع في عمليات رفع الانقاذ
ومن ثم مع العثور على اي جثمان يتم رفعه
في بعجاله يعني حتى لم نعد نشاهد وجود
لاهالي ربما او اقارب لمفقودين بالرغم من
انه ما زال هناك مفقودين في تحت الانقاض
الجهات الرسميه ربما لم تعد تعلن عن اعداد
لا تمتلك اعدادا يعني محدده لعدد
المفقودين كما تتحاشر ربما الخوض في هذا
الامر فيما يتعلق بعمليات انقاذ او انتشال
من هم تحت الركام طيله هذه المده فهناك
نوعا ما اسراع في ازاله الركام ربما هناك
اسباب امنيه حتى لا يتم يعني تكدس
البنايات المحتمل سقوطها
هناك غلق تاملي الطرق والحياه ايضا بالوضع
الامني فيها هل هو تحت السيطره الكامله ان
هناك تم تتجاوزات او استغلالا لهذه الظروف
التي تمر بها المنطقه من ضعاف النفوس كما
حدث في اوقات سابقه
فعلا حدث في اوقات سابقه لكن اليوم وخلال
الايام الماضيه هناك صرامه شديده من قبل
رجال الامن والجيش بالتحديد
لا يوجد اي تساهل في هذا الامر لا يسمح
لاي شخص غريب
بالتقرب من محيط البنايات المدمره او اين
توجد ممتلكات مثلا هنا نشاهد يعني هناك
بعض البنايات التي لم تسقط ولكن لا تزال
تحتفظ باشياء واغراض مالكيها واهلها هناك
حمايه مشدده على هذه الممتلكات تحديدا
بالنظر الى الحوادث التي حصلت من سرقه من
استغلال من محاوله السطو على ممتلكات
ثمينه قدرت هنا بخصوص في هذه المدينه فقلت
انه هناك تشدد كبير هناك شخص نريد ان
نساله ممكن تحكي عربي في عربي احكي لي كيف
ضرب المنطقه والله كنا شوي لقدام ما نتعشى
نحن في عنا عسكري في عنا الشرطي انت موجود
بخيمه هون
او في بيتي لا لا عم تنبه هاي انت متطوع
بتساعد يعني
نحن وما نتعشى صارت الزلزله قدام عيننا
بنايتين قامت القيامه يعني الله لا يعيدها
لحدا يعني
وفي فيه كانوا ناس تحت الانقاذ هناك
حوالينا
هل تشعر بالامان في هذه المدينه حتى وانت
يعني في منطقه ربما فيها خيام ام انت تخاف
الان انه يصير في زلزال
رب العالمين يعني
ما بيعلم وين رب العالمين يعني انت
عيلتكوين الان لحالك
انت
لحالي انا
وقدمت من هناك لهنا
حتى
تجربتك يعني هذا عملت تطوعي نبيل جدا انك
كم صار لك هون
لكن عائلتك مش موجوده
الناس وبتساعد في عمليات الانقاذ
منكم فاضيين من عينه
ان شاء الله سلامه عليك
فلذلك لم افوت الفرصه لاساله لماذا هو
الان هنا لكن اتضح انه قدم لتقديم
المساعده وهو يعمل على مساعده فرق الانقاذ
في متابعتك على هذه النشر نشرات المقبله
شكرا لك منها
القتاليه لرصد اثار زلزال والدمار الذي
لحق بالمباني في مدينه هاتاي جنوب البلاد
[موسيقى]
وفي سوريا مشاهدينا افاد المرصد السوري
بسقوط اربعه قتلى جراء التدافع والهلع في
حلب وطرطوس وحماه بعد شعورهم بزلزال
الجديد فيما اصيب نحو 500 واكد المرصد
انهيار وتصدع بعض المباني في جنرال
الاتاري بجرائز الزلزال الجديد وافادت
وسائل اعلام السوريه في منطقتي ادلب وحلب
بان بعض المباني انهارت وانقطعت الكهرباء
وخدمات الانترنت في بعض اجزاء المنطقه
واضاف ان العديد من الناس فروا من منازلهم
وتجمعوا في مناطق مفتوحه
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هزه ارضيه جديده ضربت تركيا شعر بها معظم
سكان شمال غرب سوريا نحن الان في مدينه
سلقين وتحديدا في شارع الكورنيش هنا حيث
تجمع العشرات بل المئات من الاهالي خوفا
من انهيار المزيد من المباني نتيجه الهزات
الارتداديه خصوصا ان هذه المدينه نالت
نصيبها من الدمار والضحايا جراء الزلزال
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
هذه الهزه الجديده ادت الانهيار مبنيين
خاليين متصدعين في مدينه جنديرس وتسببت
بانهيار بعض المباني في قرى الحمزيه
وخربه الجوز وبيت صوفان في ريف ادلب
الغربي في حين اشارت مصادر طبيه ان هناك
عددا من الاصابات اما نتيجه الخوف والهلع
او تساقط الاحجار على البعض
هذه المره وصل صدى زلزال في سوريا الى
لبنان حيث اعلنت وزاره التعليم غلق
المدارس والجامعات اليوم بعد الهزه
الارضيه الاخيره التي ضربت البلاد ياتي
ذلك بعد ان شهدت مدينه طرابلس شمال لبنان
حاله من الهلع ووسط سكان المدينه بسبب
مخاوف من انهيار منازلهم المتصدعه من
الزلزال السابق
نشطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
زعيم الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
يزور الرياض ويشيد بتطور الذي تشهده
المملكه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد في مقابله
حصريه مع العربيه قال زعيم الجمهورينا في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي قال ان السعوديه
تشهد اليوم التقدما في عده مجالات مختلفه
وان المراه السعوديه باتت تحظى بثقه كبيره
ما جعلها تتولى مناصب قياديه
زعيم الجمهورينا في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي
اضاف ان العلاقه بين الولايات المتحده
والسعوديه علاقه قويه وان البلدين حليفان
في قضايا الامن القومي وكلاهما قلق ازاء
التحديد الايراني
[موسيقى]
كشف مراسل العربيه ان القوات الاسرائيليه
شنت حمله اعتقالات واسعه في الضفه الغربيه
والقدس طالت نحو 25 مواطنا فلسطينيا حيث
اقتحمت القوات الاسرائيليه عده مدن وقورا
ومخيمات ابرزها مدينه جنين حيث دارت
اشتباكات مسلحه مع مسلحين فلسطينيين في
المدينه قبل ان تنسحب القوات الاسرائيليه
عقب مصادره مركبه واعتقال شاب دون وقوع
اصابات جراء الاشتباكات
متابعه لملف الحرب الاوكرانيه من المقرر
ان يلقي الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
اليوم خطابا امام نواب البرلمان واعضاء
الحكومه وذلك قبيل الذكرى السنويه الاولى
لبدء الحرب في اوكرانيا وبالتزامن مع مرور
سنه كامله على اعتراف موسكو باستقلال
جمهوريه
في الحادي والعشرين من فبراير 2022
الماضيه ما هذا لبدء اجتياح بري لاوكرانيا
يوم الرابع والعشرين من فبراير اي بعد
ثلاثه ايام من خطاب الاعتراف
هذا وافاد مساعد الرئيس البولندي بان
الرئيس سيطلب من بوتين من بايدن زياده
وجود قوات النيتو في بولندا وكان رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن قد وصل الى بولندا بعد
زياره مفاجئه لكياف حيث من المقرر ان
يلتقي برئيس البولندي اندريدا اليوم
الثلاثاء لمناقشه امداد كييف بالاسلحه
وتعزيز قوه الرضع لحلف الناتو حسب بيان
سابق للبيت الابيض
في نهايه هذه النشره مشاهدينا نذكر بابرز
العناوين
عشره قتل في زلزال جديد ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وسكان ثلاث دول احاسب بقوته الشديده
ترقب لخطاب بوتين اليوم تزامنا مع مرور
سنه على الاعتراف بانفصال
عن اوكرانيا
اشتباكات عنيفه ترافق اقتحام قوات
اسرائيليه لمدينه جنين في الضفه الغربيه
وشن حمله اعتقالات واسعه
نهايه هذه النص المشاهدين
[موسيقى]
بقعه من العالم تنفرد بسر من اسرار
الطبيعه نحن في الغابه دي بنشتغل تجارب
تحتوي على صناعه فريده من اهم وانذر
المجالات الصناعيه حول العالم التي تدر
الملايين من الدولارات سنويا ما هو الصمغ
العربي وما هي اسراره
العربي نورينا العالم كله بيهتم بالصمت
ولماذا تنفرد السودان بهذه الماده مهما
خاصه السبت التاسعه والنصف على شاشه
العربيه
هذه البلده الاستراتيجيه التي سيطرت عليها
القوات الروسيه منذ اليوم الاول التي تم
قصفها هنا في هذا المكان
نود توثيق هذه اللحظات هذا المبنى الذي
قصف
الاشتباكات مستمره هذه قنبله يدويه لم
تنفجر بعد نحن الان في مدينه الواقعه خارج
حدود المناطق الانفصاليه القديمه في مركز
المدينه
نحن اول محطه نصل الى هذا المكان عندنا
هنا في دانيتك اليوم
المدافع التي حقيقه الامر بالفعل هنالك
مقبره جامعيه
ايضا على هذه الممرات
هذه الجوله الحصريه التي تمكنا من الحصول
عليها ودخول بلده بوتشا
[موسيقى]
المتقدمه للبتروكيماويات تسجل خساره
مفاجئه في الربع الاخير من 2022
ومصر تحدد السعر الاسترشادي لاصدارها
الاول من الصكوك الدولاريه
وتضاعف الارباح الفصليه لبنك
من ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير اهلا وسهلا بكم الى نبض السوق
من العربيه اننا نبدا سوق من نتائج
الشركات السعوديه حيث تكبدت الشركه
المتقدمه للبتروكيماويات في الربع الرابع
من 2022 خسائر قدرها سته ملايين ريال هذا
يقارن بارباح كانت سجلتها في الفتره
المقابله من 2021 كانت بلغت 161 مليون
ريال وكان المحللون قد توقعوا تحقيق
الشركه لارباح فصليه بقيمه 17 مليون و 800
الف ريال على مدار العام 2022 باكمله فقد
تراجعت ارباح المتقدمه باربعه الى 295
مليون ريال من جانب اخر ستوزع المتقدمه
ارباح النقديه بواقع 55 هلله للسهم عن
الربع الرابع من 2022 مقارنه ب 65 هلله
كانت وزعتها في الفتره المقابله من 2021
نظره على سهم المتقدمه المتراجعه ولو انه
قللص من الخسائر الصباحيه على ان تراجعات
بواحد فاصل سبعه بالمئه عند 45 ريال و25
هلله
ويوم امس بعد اغلاق السوق اختتم البنك
السعودي للاستثمار نتائج البنوك المدرجه
حيث ارتفعت ارباح السعودي للاستثمار للربع
الرابع ب 22% الى 350 مليون ريال وجائنا
النتائج اقل من توقعات المحللين البالغه
374 مليون ريال اما على مدار العام الماضي
باكمله فقد ارتفعت الارباح باثنين واربعين
في المئه الى مليار ونصف المليار ريال
وعزا البنك ارتفاع الارباح الى ارتفاع
صافي دخل العملات الخاصه من التمويل
والاستثمارات بعشرين في المئه وانخفاض
مخصص خسائر الائتمان
كان عنده تراجع بمخصص خسائر الائتمان ب
29% نظره على سهم السعودي للاستثمار ايضا
متراجع باثنين ونصف بالمئه
حاولنا تجميع النتائج البنوك السعوديه
للعام الماضي حيث جاءت على شكل تالي ارباح
العام 2022 باكمله سجل كل القطاع المصرفي
ارباحا بلغت 62 مليار ونصف المليار هل هذا
يشكل ارتفاعا ب 28% عن العام الاسبق 2021
اما اذا نظرنا الى الربع الرابع من 2022
فقد سجلت الارباح المجمع للبنوك 16 مليار
و270 مليون ريال هذا يمثل ارتفاعا باكثر
من 32% عن الربع الرابع من 2001 2020 نظره
على اداء القطاع المصرفي منذ مطلع السنه
مقارنه مع اداء تاسيا مؤشر سوق الاسهم
السعوديه القطاع المصرفي متراجع بسبعه
فاصل واحد بالمئه منذ مطلع السنه نقارنه
باداء مؤشر سوق الاسهم السعوديه
المتراجع بواحد فاصل ثمانيه بالمئه فاذا
البنوك اند سوق اداء اقل من اداء السوق
نظره على مؤشر السوق اليوم بتداولات اليوم
يوم امس كان فقد السوق اكثر من واحد
بالمئه واليوم مستمر بالتراجعات الى
10.290 نقطه للمزيد حول اخبار السوق
والشركات ينضم الي من رياض السيد مازن
السديري رئيس الابحاث في الراجحي كافه
الاستاذ مازن صباح الخير اهلا وسهلا بك
معنا خلينا نبدا من المتقدمه لانه مفاجاه
نتائجها
المتقدمه عم تتحدث عن الكثير من العوامل
تراجع اسعار البيع ارتفاع اسعار مدخلات
الانتاج ارتفاع تكاليف الشحن واضح انه كله
اثر عليها رايكم بالنتائج
الا بالعكس هي متمشيه مع ما حدث في القطاع
يعني ايش رايتي انت النتائج يا نساء رايتي
نتائج المجموعه لم يكن مفاجئه ولا اعتقد
السوق اذا كان يتوقع شيء بعيد عن هذا يعني
هي مدخلها متغير مرتبط بغازل بروبان يعني
غاز البروبان انخفض ربعيا على اساس ربعي
في الربع الرابع تقريبا في حدود 9% ايضا
انخفض من نفس النسبه وعلى اساس سنوي 25%
فانخفاضها يعني كان الحقيقه انخفاض
منتجاتها كان ضعف البروبان
ضعف النفط اسف
فهذا اثر على سعر المدخلات لديها يعني
كانت تكلفه المدخلات منخفضه اقل من تكلفه
المنتج ضعف الصين في الربع الرابع كان قوي
او على النصف الثاني اغلاق الصيني اللي
جاء مفاجئ في الربع الاول عام 21 كان جزئي
صحيح لكن اثر على القطاع الصناعي بشكل
كبير لذلك شفت المؤشر الصناعي ارتفع
الصيني من دون الخمسين 44 55 يعني هو على
اساس
اثر على البترو كماليات في النصف الثاني
والعام الماضي رغم اسعار البترول كانت
جيده لكن الطلب صار ضعيف
الشيء الاخر ابغى اقوله هذا كان خلفنا
يعني والسوق يتوقع ننظر مستقبل ان الان
عاده الصين هل الامور تحسنت نعم تحسنت لكن
لا يعني انه
في وضع افضل يعني تحسمت الاسعار من بدات
السنه في حدود مثلا في حدود 9% لكن لا
تزال حجم الاسعار الحالي
قد لا يستطيع ان يحقق بعض التوزيعات للعام
الماضي لا يزال يعني نزل نحتاج زياده عشره
15% نستطيع ان نشعر بطمئنان ونرى لي ممكن
يحدث في القطاع شيث الاخر اللي يبغى اوضحه
انه يعتمد نوع الارتفاع
الارتفاع مرتبط باسعار البترول فبالتالي
زياده الانتاج من الصين ممكن انها تتاخر
وتكون متاثره لان احنا عندنا نخوف
الانفتاح الصيني صفه زياده انتاج صيني
يعني اتوقع المحللين عوده الصين تزيد
الطلب العالمي اربعه في الميه مثلا لكن
تزيد سبعه في المئه هذا في حاله انه مبني
على طلب لكن اذا مبني على كوستا في انبوكس
ما اعتقد لانه كثير من السب
لاي
القادم مدخلاته هي نفط
وغاز ثقيل فاذا كانت التكلفه عاليه وغير
مجديه اعتقد ان هذه الزيادات راح تكون لن
تاتي بكاملها كما يتوقع السوق راح ياتي
جزء منها اذا جاء الطلب بشكل كبير ومتحسن
ممكن فعلا يعود اكثر من ارتفاع
الكوميديتيز وهذا غير وارد على المدى
القريب لكن حتى الان احب اوضح ان ارتفاع
الاسعار اللي صاير في البتروكيماويات حتى
الان نسبي يعني لم نخرج من الغابه زي
التعبير انه الشركات ككل السنه ككل لانه
هي هلا عم تصدر ارباح سنويه بتقول لي لا
تفسر ما حصل بالربع الرابع هي تفسر ما حصل
بالسنه كامله
مثلا المتقدمه على صعيد السنه تتحدث عن
تراجع اسعار البيع 17 بالمئه وارتفاع
اسعار المدخلات 13 واربعه بالمئه فهذا
تفوت ما تفسيرك لتراجع المنتج النهائي سعر
المنتج النهائي على صعيد السنه وارتفاع
المدخلات الانتاج وهون كيف شايف الترند
رايح الفتره القادمه
ببساطه النصف الضعف الصين الجاف النصف
الثاني كان جدا قوي يعني من اسوا
الانخفاضات او حالات الطلب اللي شفناها في
الفتره كما كيماويات خلال العقد الاخير
هذا من ناحيه ضعف المنتج النهائي بسبب
الاغلاق الجزء اللي صاير في الصين ايضا
اوروبا دخلت في حاله شبه الشلل يعني بعد
الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه وضعف المدخلات
الغاز لديها واغلقت كثير بعد المصانع التي
تعتمد على الالغاز الطبيعي وتم توظيفها
اكثر لصالح انتاج الطاقه الكهرباء لذلك
تلقين سعر الميثانول لقله الصبر السبلاي
مدعوم اكثر من كثير من الغازات راحت تنتج
البت راح تنتج اليوريا او راحت تنتج
الكهرباء ارجع لك
الجزئيه هذا بالنسبه للمنتج النهائي ضعف
الطلب المدخلات اسعار البترول اسعار
البترول ظل جيده مع ضعف السطلاء يعني
اساسيات صناعه البترول كانت جيده في عام
22 يعني كان السعر متوازن في الثمانينات
من
الاسباب كثيره والان حتى عوده الصين راح
تزيد الطلب على البترول وهنا الضغط اللي
ممكن يصير على بعض
وراح تبقى اسعار المدخلات عاليه سؤال
مرتبط ماذا عن تسعير اسهم شركات
البتروكيماويات بالسوق
الانسر تنزيل
وتاثيراته على الطلب على المنتج النهائي
كل السوق صحح لابسه بدايه السنه صار
فيرالي جزئي وبعدين عاد السوق التصحيح انا
اعتقد هي في الرينج الطبيعي بس اعتقد من
المبكر الحديث عن ابصايد من ناحيه اخرى
نتائج اعمالها صراحه يعني لم نتوقف عندها
بشكل الوافي لانه كانت فتره الزلزال
بتركيا الاسبوع الماضي يعني بالفعل
تغطياتنا شوي كانت ضعيفه لوبرف ارتفاع 32%
بالارباح السنويه على وقع ارتفاع 20%
بالمبيعات تتحدث عن ارتفاع هوامش تكسير
زيوت الاساس والم نتجات الثانويه وارتفاع
بكميات البيع ما رايكم بالنتائج وايضا
تاثيراته على سام لانه ملفت
طرحه لم يكن اداء السهم جيد مقارنه مع سعر
الطرح
تحسن اداء الاسبوعين الاخيرات تحسن صار
فيرالي جيد للسهم لكن خلينا نتكلم عن
الشيء بالنسبه للهوامش التكسير صحيح انها
يعني استفادت من الوضع الحالي لكن انا
اعتقد هناك عنصرين مهمين للشركه عنصر يعني
هيكل اللي هو اسعار البترول في وضع مريح
يعني الفتره القادمه اعطيها يستمر يعطيها
اتوقع هو مش جيده لكن الشيء الاخر هو
التوسعات القادمه في الشركه طبعا هذا
نتكلم عن شيء ومستقبل يعني الزياده
والتوسعه اللي راح تحدث فيه موبايل ارجع
لك على النتائج اللي حدثت في الربع الرابع
حدث شيئين المهمين النتائج اللي زي ما
تفضلت يعني عن الهوامش وايضا نعتقد انه تم
تم تغيير ايضا محاسبه ايضا للشركه اثر في
الربع الرابع يعني جاء مؤثرات وكلها على
الربع الرابع لذلك الهوامش ارتفعت يعني
الهوامش تجرينا في حدود 40% المتوسط انه
يكون 20 لكن اعتقد ان هذا التعديلات
انعكست على الربع الرابع يعني كانت متركزه
يفترض اننا احنا نوزعها على السمك بشكل
عام كانت جيده شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ مازن
الاسديري رئيس الابحاث في الراجحي كابتل
اهلا وسهلا بك
مشاهديناخذ وقفه مع فاصل نتابع بعدها ونبض
السوق وفيه القيمه السوقيه لمجموعه
تنخفض دون ال 100 مليار دولار
يا سنوات حتى الواحد على الفطور ربع رغيف
مع ست حبات زيتون
شو ابرز الامراض اللي واجهتوها في المعتقل
انقطاع تام عن الخارجي نهائيا
قال في ناس
داخل المعتقل ويطلعوهم
الناشط السياسي والروائي السوري مصطفى
خليفه الذاكره السياسيه الجزء الثالث
الجمعه العاشره والنصف على شاشه العربيه
ولكن ما يجعلك مختلفا حقيقه هو قدرتك على
الرؤيه من زوايا متعدده لتغطي الحدث من
جميع الجوانب ما يجعلك الافضل هو قيامك
بتجزئه الملفات والربط بين عناصرها مع
الاستعانه بالخبراء والمحللين
لجعل الاخبار اكثر فهما العربيه
360 من الاحد الى الخميس العاشره على شاشه
العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد في نبض السوق في مصر
اظهرت وثيقه اطلعت عليها ان مصر طرحت سعرا
استرشاديا اوليا على صكوك دولاريا في نطاق
11.6 بالمئه لسقوط دولاريه لاجل ثلاث
سنوات ما فقط توقعات السوق وتسعى مصر لجمع
ما يصل الى مليار ونصف المليار دولار من
خلال اصدار صكوك دولاريه هو اول اصدار من
الصقوق السياديه للبلاد وعينت مصر كلا من
مصرف ابوظبي الاسلامي والامارات دبي
الوطني كابيتال وبنك ابو ظبي الاول وسيتي
وكريدي اجريكول
لمساعدتها في اصدار الصكوك
قبل ان نذهب الى فهمها لنسالها اكثر عن
هذا التسعير لهذه السقوط الدولاريه هذا
سعر الدولار مقابل الجنيه المصري اليوم عم
يتراجع بعض الشيء الى 30.58 لنذهب فلان
اذا الى زميلتنا فهيمه اللي مطلعه دائما
على اخر اخبار مصر وخاصه هذا الاصدار من
الصكوك فهيما اولا خلينا نتحدث عن التسعير
هل كان مفاجئا وحجم الاقبال لدينا ارقام
حول الاقبال وممن الاقبال على هذه الصكوك
مرحبا نادين بالطبع هذا السعر لم يكن في
حزبان الحكومه المصريه كان مدى السعري
الذي تم وضعه قبل بدايه المحادثات مع
المؤسسات الماليه كان في حدود من سته ونصف
الى سبعه ونصف في المئه ولكن من خلال
المحادثات التي تمت مع المؤسسات على مدار
ثلاثه ايام الماضيه اتضح ان هذا السعر
غير ممكن تغطيه الصكوك من خلاله وانه وقد
اخبرهم منسق الطرح بالفعل انه لابد من رفع
سعر بصوره كبيره ولذلك
وجدنا هذا التغيير في السعر الاسترشادي
الذي تم
التنويه اليه اللي هو احد عشر فاصل سته من
عشره في المئه
بالطبع
الحكومه المصريه لديها التزامات خلال
الشهر الحالي تتجاوز المليارين دولار منها
استحقاق سندات باليورو ب مليار 250 مليون
دولار هذا
اعتقد انه يلزم الحكومه المصريه بقبول هذا
العائد المرتفع على الثقوك
ما تنام الي من انباء ان التغطيه في حدود
المره ونصف تقريبا هناك تفكير من الحكومه
المصريه في رفع قيمه الاصدار الى ملياري
دولار وذلك لتغطيه الالتزامات التي عليها
وايضا
نعلم ان اصدارات السقوق ستكون في حدود
الخمسه مليارات دولار على مدار هذا العام
للتخفيف لتكون الاصدار القادم في حدود
المليار ونصف وسيكون تقريبا في شهر يونيو
القادم
فهيم هل نعلم من من الاقبال يعني اليوم عم
بتقولي في اقبال كبير على صقوق لانه
تسعيره كما ذكرنا مرتفع عم نتحدث عن تسعير
فوق ال 11% هل هو اقبال من مؤسسات دوليه
محليه يعني هي دولاريه فبالتالي ممن
الاقبال
بصوره كبيره نادين الاقبال من مؤسسات
خليجيه
حيث يتوقع ان تكون النسبه الاكبر لدى هذه
المؤسسه شكرا جزيلا لك فهمه زايد مراسلتنا
في مصر باقون معك بالطبع لكل جديد حول هذه
الصكوك فهم
في بريطانيا ارتفعت ارباح قبل احتساب
الضرائب 92% في الربع الرابع من العام
الماضي لتصل الى خمسه مليارات ومئتين
مليون دولار وجاءت النتائج اعلى من توقعات
المحللين البالغه اربعه مليارات وتسعمائه
مليون دولار هذا وارتفعت المخصصات الى
ثلاثه مليارات
ان تبلغ 3.2 مليار دولار من جانب اخر رفع
توزيعاته من الارباح الى اعلى مستوى في
اربع سنوات مضيفا انه قد يقوم بتقديم
توزيعات استثنائيه في العام المقبل ويحاول
دعوات بالفصل نشاطاته الاسيويه عن الغربيه
وهو ما يطالب في يطالب فيه احد اكبر
المساهمين في ظل اداء البنك في السنوات
الاخيره
هذا سهم
منذ مطلع السنه منذ مطلع السنه 20%
لارتفاع اليوم بعد لم تبدا التداولات
السوق في لندن النظره على تداولات الاسواق
الاسيويه التي كانت على ضعف صباحا ولا
تزال بالفعل على تراجع حاده بواحد فاصل
ثمانيه بالمئه من بعد ما كان قفز يوم امس
وسط تقرير من جولد ايجابي على الاسهم
الصينيه نظره على العملات الرئيسيه دولار
لا يزال قريب من المستويات العليا اللي
كان سجلها بثلاثه اسابيع الماضيه كان سجل
الارتفاعات قويه دولار امام العملات
الاخرى في ظل ارقام اقتصاديه قويه من
الولايات المتحده تشير الى امكانيه
استمرار الفيدرالي برفع الفائده للمزيد
حول كل هذه المواضيع نذهب الى كارينا تنضم
الينا الان من لندن كارينا صباح الخير هل
من تعليق اضافي على سبيسي لانه النتائج
بالفعل ملفته اليوم
يعني ملفت نادين انه اكيد هناك ارتفاع
كبير في الارباح قبل الضرائب 92% هذا
بالنسبه لي الارباح الصافيه خلال الربع
الرابع من السنه ولكن الملفت انه السهم
كان تراجع في بورصه اليوم بتابع نحن ننتظر
تداولات السهم في البورصه هنا في لندن
ولكن كان